hey it's Jessica Simpson I'm here at
BuzzFeed and I am here to answer 30
questions in 3 minutes I can do it it's
really vain to say my own but a song off
of my audiobook party of one Amy Grant
Ryan Gosling my children my husband and
[Music]
angel employee of the month
my ankles are now normal thank God
purpose fun clear 26 25 24 one of those
24 I shadow ABS my ovulation app so I
never get pregnant again
I wish social media existed when I first
became famous that I'm having sixth ugly
I was with 98 degrees in people Teen
People magazine stuffed twice-baked
being an astronaut the notebook because
I wouldn't do the sex scene being an
astronaut Brad Pitt Sienna Miller
perspective I'm always sticking my foot
my mouth up
let me see but to impress somebody
colored my hair I don't think I've
really changed oh no I wasn't nervous
about any of it I mean I don't really
feel guilty about it but my best
pleasure is making love to my husband
thank you so much that was so fun I want
more questions like this so keep asking
them to me Instagram them to me that's a
little fun thing to do
open book is in stores now which is so
exciting thank you guys so much for
having me
[Music]